hey everyone we all are aware of the
fact that blockchain has come a long way
in the previous 10 years it all began
with bitcoin which introduced the first
type of blockchain public blockchain
the bitcoin blockchain is also known as
the first blockchain technology
generation
today we are at a point where there are
various types of blockchain technology
each of which serves a certain purpose
and addresses a specific problem or
group of problems
more importantly many businesses are
employing them to maximize the benefits
so here i am with a new video of simply
learn on the types of blockchain to give
you a deep understanding of the various
types of blockchains
so let's get started
but before proceeding please do hit the
bell icon and the subscribe button to
never miss an update from simply learn
so
let's have a look at the objectives that
we are going to cover in this video
at first we will have a crisp
introduction to what is blockchain
following that we will understand why we
need different types of blockchain
after that we will look into the various
types of
blockchain
then we will explore which type of
blockchain you should choose
and at the end we will summarize
whatever we learned in this video
so coming to what is blockchain
blockchain is a decentralized data
ledger that may be safely exchanged
blockchain technology allows a
restricted number of people to share
information transactional data from
numerous sources may be readily
collected integrated and shared using
blockchain cloud services
basically data is divided into common
blocks that are linked together using
cryptographic hashes as unique ids
data integrity is insured via blockchain
which uses a single source of truth to
eliminate data duplication
and increase security
fraud and data tampering is prevented in
a blockchain system since data can't be
changed without the permission of a
forum or the parties
the contents of a blockchain ledger can
be shared but not changed if someone
tries to change data all participants
will be notified and the perpetrator
will be identified
now let's understand why do we need
different types of blockchain
so the most basic requirement or
application of a blockchain is to
conduct transactions or data exchanges
across a secure network
however how people use blockchain and
distributed ledger technologies or
networks varies from one situation to
the next
for example bitcoin is a digital
cryptocurrency that is transacted using
blockchain and dlt technology because
anyone from anywhere in the world can
become a node verify other nodes and
exchange bitcoins
this form of a blockchain network is a
public network
but on the other hand assume that a bank
is utilizing a private blockchain
network
it will be a password-protected network
that only banks approved members will
have access to as a result
no one outside of this restricted
network has access to bank information
similar to these instances the
blockchain network can be set up in a
variety of ways based on usage and
requirements
so now that we know the necessity of
different types of blockchain let's have
a look at the different types of
blockchain
there are majorly four types of
blockchain first is public blockchain
second is private blockchain
third is hybrid blockchain
and the last but not the least is
consortium blockchain
now let's understand each one of these
blockchains in detail starting with
public blockchain
now a public blockchain is a
permissionless distributed ledger that
anybody can join and conduct
transactions on it is a non-restrictive
form of the ledger in which each peer
has a copy
this also means that anyone with an
internet connection can access the
public blockchain
this user has access to historical and
contemporary records as well as the
ability to perform mining operations
which are sophisticated calculations
required to verify transactions and add
them to the ledger
on the network
no valid record or transaction may be
modified and because the source code is
usually open source anybody can verify
the transaction
uncover errors and often fixes
now let's have a look at some of the
advantages and disadvantages of the
public blockchain
starting with advantages
first is trustable public blockchain
nodes do not need to know or trust each
other because the proof-of-work
procedure ensures that no transactions
are fraudulent as a result one can trust
public blockchain without having to
trust individual nodes
second is secure a public network can
have as many participants and nodes as
it wants making it a secure network
the higher the network size the more
records are distributed and the more
difficult it is for hackers to hack the
entire network
third is
open and transparent the data on a
public blockchain is transparent to all
member nodes
every authorized node has a copy of the
blockchain records or digital ledger as
a result the blockchain system
as a whole is entirely open
and transparent
now
let's discuss its disadvantages
first is lower tps in a public
blockchain the number of transactions
per second is extremely low this is due
to the fact that it is a large network
with many nodes and it takes time for
each node to verify a transaction and do
proof of work
second is scalability
as we just observed in the previous
point public blockchain transactions are
processed and completed slowly
this has a negative impact on
scalability because the more we try to
expand the network size the slower it
will get
and third is high energy consumption
proof of work is an energy intensive
method that necessitates the use of
specialized systems to execute a complex
algorithm
it's a problem from both an
environmental and a financial aspect the
proof of work device is expensive and
requires as much energy as the entire
country of ireland
technology will undoubtedly need to
develop energy efficient consensus
methods
now let's have a look at some of its use
cases
first is voting governments can use a
public blockchain to conduct voting
ensuring openness and trust
and second is fundraising the public
blockchain can be used by businesses or
initiatives to improve transparency and
trust
so now that we have covered public
blockchain let's move on to the next
blockchain in the list which is a
private blockchain
a private blockchain is a blockchain
network that operates in a restricted
context such as a closed network or is
controlled by a single entity
might function similarly to a public
blockchain network in terms of
peer-to-peer connectivity and
decentralization
this blockchain is substantially smaller
private blockchains are often run on a
small network within a firm or
organization rather than being open to
anybody who wants to contribute
processing power permission blockchain
and business blockchain are two more
terms for them
moving on to its advantages
first is speed
private blockchain transactions are
faster in the case of private blockchain
this
means that the transactions per second
rate is higher
this is due to the fact that a private
network has a smaller number of nodes
than a public network this shortens the
time it takes for all nodes
in a network
to agree on or verify a transaction
second is
scalability
so private blockchains have a lot of
room for growth that is you can tailor
the size of your private blockchain to
meet your specific requirements
and this makes the private blockchains
particularly scalable since they allow a
company to easily raise or decrease the
size of their network
now coming on to its disadvantages
first is need for trust building
in a restricted network there are fewer
participants than in a private network
specifically within an organization when
co-workers are familiar with one another
they must establish confidence in order
to send secret data over a network
second is lower security
because a private blockchain network has
fewer nodes or members it is more
vulnerable to a security compromise if
one of the nodes acquire access to the
network central administration system
it has access to all of the other nodes
this makes it easier for a node to
compromise the entire private blockchain
and steal data
third is centralization
private blockchains are eliminated
in that they require a central identity
and access management system to function
this system provides
full administrative and monitoring
capabilities
and this entire structure runs counter
to one of the tenants of blockchain
technology like decentralization
now let's dive down into its use cases
first is supply chain management a
private blockchain can be used to manage
a company's supply chain
second is asset ownership a private
blockchain can be used to track and
verify assets
and third is internal voting internal
voting is also possible with the help of
private blockchain
now that we are done with private
blockchain let's move on to the next one
which is hybrid blockchain
organization who desire the best of both
worlds will sometimes employ a hybrid
blockchain a type of blockchain that
includes characteristics of both private
and public blockchain it allows
businesses to create a private
permission-based system alongside a
public permissionless system
letting them to regulate who has access
to certain data stored on the blockchain
and what data is made public
in a hybrid blockchain transactions and
records are typically not made public
but they can be validated if necessary
such as by granting access via smart
contract
now coming to the advantages of hybrid
blockchain
first is secure
one of the major
advantages of hybrid blockchain is that
it operates within a closed environment
preventing outside hackers from
launching a 51 attack on the network
second is cost effective
it also save guards privacy while
allowing third-party contact
transactions are inexpensive
and quick and it scales better than a
public blockchain network
now coming to the disadvantages first is
the lack of transparency
because information can be hidden this
type of blockchain isn't completely
transparent
second is lessoncenter upgrading can be
difficult and users have no incentive to
participate in or contribute to the
network
now let's look into its use cases
real estate
real estate companies can use hybrid
networks to run their systems and offer
information to the public
retail
the hybrid network can also help
retailers streamline the processes
and highly regulated markets hybrid
blockchain are also well suited to
highly regulated areas like the banking
sector
now let's move on to the last type of
blockchain bridges the consortium
blockchain
a consortium blockchain also known as a
federation blockchain
is similar to a hybrid blockchain in
that it has both private and public
blockchain capabilities
however it differs in that it involves
various organizational members working
together on a decentralized network
the consensus method in a consortium
blockchain are controlled by
pre-determined nodes it has a validated
node that is responsible for initiating
receiving and validating transactions
transactions can be initiated or
received by member nodes
now
that we have what is consortium
blockchain let's have a look at its
advantages and disadvantages
advantages
first is secure
in comparison to a public blockchain
network consortium blockchain is more
secure scalable and efficient
it also has access controls just like
private and hybrid blockchains
in disadvantages we have lack of
transparency
in comparison to public blockchain the
consortium blockchain is less
transparent it can still be hacked if a
member node is compromised and the
blockchain's own rules can make the
network unusable
so now moving towards its use cases
first we have banking and payments
consortium can be
formed by a group of bank working
together they have control over which
nodes will validate transactions
second is research to share research
data and outcomes a consortium
blockchain can be employed
and third we have food tracking it is
also app for food tracking in various
food apps like spiggy tomato ubereats
etc
now that we have covered all the major
details of all the types of blockchains
let's understand which blockchain you
need to choose
so each blockchain has its own set of
benefits as a result there is no
straightforward solution to the question
of which blockchain to choose however
access your requirements to ensure that
you have made the best decision
now let's summarize what we learned in
this video
first we understood what is blockchain
then we explored how important it is to
have different types of blockchain
according to the rising demand for it
after that we covered different types of
blockchains with the advantages and
disadvantages as well as their use cases
and later we answered the question of
which blockchain one should choose
so this was all about types of
blockchain i hope you enjoyed this video
on types of blockchain and learned
something new from it
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates and videos from
simply
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here